you would think your relationship with
Eddie would have been the closest
because the two of you made beautiful
music together it's it's it's it's a
love story if you think about two guys
who could write songs you could write
lyrics give him musical ideas he could
come in with these massive riffs you
would think it was a romance made in
heaven but it's not I never I don't
understand well it was no it was Howard
it 100% was for nine years the 10th year
in Van Halen it just went sideways you
our manager died another manager came
men he started poisoning Ed now saying
hey Sammy thinks it's his band Michael
tell you it's like I I was innocent they
you know he they just all turned on me
because I didn't like this manager you
know we wanted a different manager I
wanted a different manager and uh and of
course this guy lasted five minutes and
he was gone so I was right in the end
but I don't I didn't being right wasn't
a good thing in this case so this is
kind of heavy for this time in the
morning but no one want I know about you
and your father and your father I you
know I know you loved your father but
your father was a difficult man the guy
had a horrible drinking problem he was
difficult to deal with you know it's
weird doesn't it remind you in some ways
of you going back to your father working
with Eddie Van Halen because Eddie had
his problems with substance Eddie kind
of is like your father in a weird way
isn't he well he he had addiction
problems like my father had Eddie wasn't
violent you know that was the only great
beautiful thing about Eddie when we'd
get drunk we'd end up crying together
you know what I mean it's like we
weren't we didn't fight towards the end
we started fighting about other stuff
but uh no my dad was violent but you
know I I think it's true I one thing
that makes sense what you said is that I
never thought I had a drinking problem I
never thought I had a drug problem when
I was doing coke once in a while I would
I never really did I can still tell you
I don't I don't you know the thing is is
that you when you're around people that
have a bad addiction like my father who
would drink himself into the ground
until he had to be taken to the hospital
then he would quit for 2 weeks or a
month and he'd start over again when
you're around somebody that bad you see
somebody like Ed Al and Mike and the way
we were partying it's like ah we're okay
I know worse guys than that hey Jimmy
henck died of an over you know so yeah
your your your relative standards of
what's bad and what's okay is was pretty
low for for people that drank all day
you know what I mean it's like it didn't
bother me I thought as long as until
until people can't do their job then
that's when I I step in and say hey this
is [__] up man you know you played
like [__] and it's embarrassing to me to
have to try to sing you're so Out Of
Tune you know that's what was going on
in the reunion tour and that that's when
we bumped heads that's when it really
got bad it was like well you know I
can't can't be and it must and it must
have been shocking for you Sammy because
this is the great Eddie Van Halen and
he's [__] up his Parts on the tour
and you're like whoa this isn't the guy
I know this is the guy who takes such
pride in his musicianship right yeah
yeah it just it was it was really it
really strange to see that happen but
you know Ed was sick I didn't realize no
one realized realiz how sick he really
was obviously until it was over it's
really a shame I I mean if there's
anything I regret it's ever going
through any hardships with Eddie because
knowing he was sick like that I would
have been so much more compassionate but
you know I didn't know until after it it
was too late you know but that's how we
got back together in the end because
George Lopez called me and said you got
to call Eddie I said I call I've reached
out to him before man give me my number
he's going no you got to call him he
said he's really sick I said what you
know I knew he I knew he was always
battling with this tongue cancer and all
that stuff but I thought it was cool and
that's what I called him and that's when
we you know made friends again it's
beautiful